[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur tv 78 ce mercredi 19 mai une édition
spéciale sur cette deuxième étape du
déconfinement voici les titres m
concert de réouverture à l'auditorium de
la batterie de guyancourt ou encore
toute première séance au nouveau cinéma
ugc de plaisir la culture revient en
scène pour cette deuxième étape du
déconfinement un soulagement pour les
acteurs du monde culturel yvelinois un
soulagement aussi pour l'économie les
commerces non essentiels comme les
magasins de vêtements ont ouvert leurs
portes dès l'aube ce matin
bars et restaurants ont pu ressortir
leurs terrasses enfin un retour
progressif au jeu pour les sports de
contact en intérieur première étape
aujourd'hui pour eux avec le retour des
sportifs amateurs mineurs en intérieur
et avec contact les piscines intérieures
peuvent-elles aussi à nouveau ouvrir
leurs portes nous inviter pour en parler
philippe femmes président de l'entente
le chesnay versailles 78 de basket et
agnès scouarnec directrice du centre
aquatique de montigny le bretonneux
avant cela un petit rappel succinct ce
19 mai c'est donc cette deuxième étape
du déconfinement de choses à retenir
notamment le couvre-feu passe de 19h à
21h et la réouverture des lieux
culturels commerce non essentiels bars
et restaurants également la reprise en
douceur du sport en intérieur
la prochaine étape ce sera le 9 juin
mais d'abord retour sur cette première
journée de déconfinement
et pour débuter cette édition spéciale
en duplex avec nous justin brasier
journaliste de tv 78 bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes à l'auditorium de la
salle de spectacle la batterie de
guyancourt pour le premier concert de
réouverture comment ça se passe sur
place
alors là on se trouve devant le bâtiment
et l'honneur puisque en fait les
artistes sont en train de faire les
dernières balance le spectacle affiche
complet
premier spectacle auquel les spectateurs
le public assistera depuis le mois
d'octobre donc là ça y est c'est la
reprise et pour fêter à cette
réouverture
et bien la batterie de guyancourt a
prévu un spectacle surprise spectacle
qui débutera à 19 heures jusqu'à 20
heures 40 environ
au programme concerts à théâtre hip hop
ou encore compte une douzaine d'artistes
va performer à ce soir et je suis
d'ailleurs accompagné de deux d'entre
eux yoann demeyer professeur de
percussions pour soir est également
françois lamargot danseur et chorégraphe
alors qu'est ce que ça vous fait à tous
les deux à de revenir devant public et
de performer à nouveau ce soir je suis
vraiment très heureux de pouvoir revenir
aujourd'hui après tant d'attenté prudent
bien sûr sur les jours à venir en
gardant bien les gestes barrière mais
particulièrement heureux de pouvoir
rencontrer comme aujourd'hui un artiste
comme françois avec laquelle nous allons
faire un très beau une très belle
performance qui lie donc danses et
percussions et je suivais 13 02 40
pareillement c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup d'émotion de reprendre après
tant de temps après huit mois d'absence
sur les planches ça fait forcément une
certaine émotion de remonter sur scène
donc le premier sentiment c'est surtout
la joie heureux d'être là revoilà il
plus pouvoir échanger et puis de créer
des rencontres aussi impromptue
finalement qui n'était pas prévu et
qu'ils se sont créées par voilà au
dernier moment et donc qu'est-ce que
vous nous présenter ce soir une surprise
mais ça vous le savez déjà
on fera deux pièces classiques mais
complètement revisitée pour être mis au
goût du jour et j'en dis pas plus parce
qu'il faut garder la surprise
voilà exactement rendez vous tout à
l'heure pour en voir plus en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que il y aura plein de
choses très différentes autant dans nous
ce qu'on propose que d'autres artistes
présents je pense qu'il y aura une
une gamme très large de dans
l'artistique voilà du théâtre à la danse
à la musique voilà parler merci beaucoup
yoann et france quoi d'avoir été avec
nous vous l'aurez compris à eléonore la
soirée sera ponctuée de plusieurs
prestations à surprises pendant près de
deux heures au niveau du protocole
sanitaire je rappelle le public et bien
sûr masqué il y aura un sens de
circulation du gel à disposition et puis
le public sera assis avec un espacement
entre chaque groupe
la jauge étant limité il y aura 80
personnes qui assisteront à ce spectacle
et on leur souhaite évidemment un bon
concert merci justin radio pour toutes
ces précisions merci aux artistes et
encore une fois bon concert et qui dit
reprise de la culture dix reprises aussi
des salles obscures six mois après les
dernières séances les yvelinois peuvent
enfin renouer avec le septième art les
cinémas ont ouvert sous certaines
conditions
un sujet de bixente mais rien senti
steben
[Musique]
votre don tout ce cinéma un soulagement
pour les clients du nouveau cinéma ugc
de plaisir qu'ils peuvent enfin
retourner dans leur salle une attente
beaucoup trop longue pour certains
amoureux du grand écran n'ont passé
beaucoup de temps au cinéma voir deux
voire trois fois par semaine
souvent les après midi ou en soirée les
week-ends voilà donc c'est plutôt cette
prévision là qui va qui va arriver on
reprend le rythme d'avant exactement on
va rattraper le temps perdu il ya plein
de films qui nous attendent et qu'on
attend des spectateurs qui acceptent les
quelques mesures sanitaires en place
pour leur permettre d'accéder aux salles
six personnes maximum d'eux-mêmes lien
social avec deux sièges d'écart par
groupe
tout ceci pour respecter les jauges
gouvernementale on respecte
scrupuleusement toutes les règles
sanitaires qui nous ont été édictées
avec un protocole strict très stricte
une jauge à 35% qui sera applicable
normalement jusqu'au 8 juin prochain et
à partir d'une oeuvre on passera à 65% à
l'ugc de plaisir ce n'est pas une
réouverture mais bien une ouverture un
premier acte estivale pour le cinéma qui
s'annonce mouvementée tout ce qu'on
entend comme message de sympathie se
transforme aujourd'hui par la venue des
nouveaux spectateurs à l'ugc plaisir
donc moi j'ai aucune crainte pour
accueillir les clients et je pense
qu'ils seront là en hongrie plus
particulièrement cette année il ya
beaucoup de sorties gens j'en retiens
deux qui sont très attendus le 21
juillet où vous avez camelot et le 4
août normalement vous avez oss 117 le
contre et deux films français qui sont
très attendus et qui je pense vont se
retrouver et trouver largement leur
public même en période estivale entre
les longs métrages d'aignan pu
bénéficier que de quelques jours de
diffusion en octobre 2020 et les
nouvelles sorties
onze films sont à découvrir dans les
neuf salles de plaisir cette semaine
si toutes les ouvertures et est attendue
celle ci particulièrement pour nos
journalistes de la rédaction
michael almy d'eau et justine brasier
après sept mois de fermeture ils ont
testé aux côtés d'yves in war un patient
la réouverture des terrasses des bars et
des restaurants
reportage elle était fermée depuis
octobre dernier at on enfin a rouvert
dans les yvelines à les terrasses sont
ouvertes depuis aujourd'hui 1 ce midi
il y en a certains qui n'ont pas hésité
à venir dès aujourd'hui dès les
premières heures pour passer un petit
temps en terrasse maël bah ouais c'est
ça on profite un peu entre deux examens
de venir soutenir un peu les restaurants
les bars on est du métier nous aussi
encore en apprentissage jusqu'à la fin
de l'année mais ont trouvé sur important
et puis après c'est sympa de se
retrouver avec les amis autour d'une
bonne bière bell est ce que c'était
important pour vous aussi d'être ici
aujourd'hui
ben oui évidemment c'est qu'être à table
avec les copains c'est toujours un
moment qui est sympa ça nous manquait à
tous c'était un peu aussi notre endroit
où tout le monde se réunissent et après
les cours donc sac de retrouver sa
maintenance et c'est important et aussi
pour les restaurateurs du coup de se
relancer un peu dans l'activité je pense
que c'est c'est bon pour tout le monde
alors ce midi ils seront nombreux malgré
à la météo ici on prévoit environ 80
personnes en extérieur si la météo le
permet et 60 personnes si il fait
mauvais nous allons justement rencontré
le gérant de cette institution qui est
présenté ici à saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 26 ans franck alors franck est ce
que c'est important pour vous
d'ouvrir aujourd'hui je crois que vous
en aviez très envie bonjour michael bay
et oui c'était important parce qu'on a
tous soif
même si la météo n'est pas des plus
clémentes c'est comme en bretagne
un coup je te vois un coup je te vois
pas où une autre situation il fait beau
plusieurs fois par jour donc oui c'est
important pour pour tout le monde et
puis pour le dans la tête surtout
comment ça s'est passé pour
l'organisation c'était compliqué à
mettre en place non pas plus compliqué
que ça mais bon évidemment c'est une
réouverture 1 6 mois ferme et il ya des
automatismes qui sont perdus des choses
à remettre et donc mon l'a fait au mieux
on pense accueillir quand même pas mal
de gens je pense que ça à venir déjà
11h30 on a déjà un petit peu de monde
donc levé ce que vous espérez pour les
prochaines semaines déjà avoir le
maximum de monde pour la réouverture
définitive le 9 juin avec du public en
intérieur ben évidemment du monde mais
surtout que ça se passe bien
voilà qu'on soit un peu dans la fête et
que la fête soit pas gâchée par des
mauvaises choses
et puis évidemment que ça y est au plus
vite pour qu'on puisse réouvrir à
l'intérieur si la météo n'est pas là
merci beaucoup franck en tout cas on l'a
compris à beaucoup de monde sur les
terrasses malgré une météo capricieuse
on espère que la météo s'améliorant dans
les prochaines semaines évidemment pour
avoir un maximum de monde ici sur ce
bistrot du théâtre à saint quentin en
yvelines
moi je vais un petit peu profité et
boire un petit verre profitez-en bien
michael almy d'euros et c'était aussi le
grand jour pour les commerces dits non
essentiels le centre commercial lusine à
vélizy a enfin ouvert ses portes
un soulagement pour la direction mais
aussi pour la clientèle
reportage de bérangère bourgoin et
astrid bergère les commerces non
essentiels aux rouvert ce mercredi 19
mai lusine centre commercial spécialisé
dans la haute lesse de la mode et de la
maison à vélizy était fermé depuis le 5
mars
c'est un soulagement bien évidemment on
avait besoin les commerçants et nous de
ba de pouvoir à nouveau retrouver nos
clients et puis on est extrêmement
confiants dans notre modèle
au vu du contexte économique des plus
moroses où l'ensemble des acteurs et des
filières de distribution ont été
affectés bien évidemment la houlette
tire son épingle du jeu et pendant cette
crise des stocks dans les magasins se
sont accumulés ici on récupère les
invendus de l'année précédente
dès aujourd'hui d'ailleurs les clients
peuvent bénéficier dans notre centre de
quantité et de qualité de stocks très
importants sur lesquels sont d'ores et
déjà affecté des remises et les
commerçants attendait cette réouverture
avec impatience je suis très heureux je
suis très enthousiaste et je suis
contente de retrouver le centre et tout
notre petit clientes sont au rendez vous
etc mais c'est super qu'on est très très
content ici dans le sentier à beaucoup
de clientes fidèles
les clients eux étaient présents dès
l'ouverture à 12 heures je suis ravi
pour les commerçants qui puisse enfin
aurait ouvrir leurs magasins et avoir
une activité pouvoir avant tout leurs
produits
il va cueillir avant tout des clients
revivent un peu normalement je dois à
dix mes deux filles pour un mariage et
je préfère aller sur place dans un
magasin pour essayer surtout pour des
enfants de change beaucoup de taille de
retrouver le chemin des magasins ça fait
du bien j'étais content de pouvoir le
faire
ouvert habituellement du mardi au
dimanche le centre accueillera
exceptionnellement du public ce lundi 24
mai les clubs de sport et les centres
aquatiques peuvent eux aussi à nouveau
accueillir sportifs et amateurs
enfin sous conditions pour en parler
nous accueillons en visioconférence avec
nous philippe femmes bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le président de l'entente le
chesnay versailles 78 basket également
avec nous en visioconférence a nié
scouarnec bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
directrice du centre aquatique du lac de
montigny le bretonneux
alors aujourd'hui pour vous 2 c'est
également la reprise du moins une
reprise partielle philippe femmes à
compter de ce 19 mai ce les mineurs sont
autorisé à s'entraîner en intérieur et
avec contact pour les majeures il faudra
attendre encore jusqu'au 9 juin 3e étape
du déconfinement pour les entraînements
d'ailleurs en intérieur et sans contact
d'abord philippe femmes
quel est votre sentiment quand ce jour
de réouverture de reprise pour le basket
bah c'est un c'est un grand jour parce
qu'effectivement pour incertaine d'une
catégorie ça fait de nombreux mois que
nous étions en attente et c'est la bonne
surprise par rapport au 19 mai c'est que
vis-à-vis de nos mineurs c'est à dire
des catégories u 7 à u 18 c'est à dire
des babys jusqu'aux cadets il ya
effectivement possibilité de reprendre
avec contente donc avec opposition et
donc de pouvoir se configurer dans le
cadre d'un jeu normal et pour nous
évidemment c'est le
l'occasion évidemment de retravailler
nos fondamentaux et de pouvoir jeudi
relative et nos jeunes à venir sur le
chemin des gymnases
car effectivement la crains que nous
avions c'était que avec cette
interruption très importante
il est un peu perdue je dirais le chemin
de deux gymnases et aujourd'hui c'est
une grande joie et tous les entraîneurs
évidemment si je dirais à pied d'oeuvre
pour effectivement à partir
d'aujourd'hui et jusqu'à la fin de la
saison
essayez de les stimuler à reprendre
leurs sensations et aussi à se
réinscrire la saison prochaine
il est coaché au mieux on imagine bien
de votre côté annie scouarnec et les
centres aquatiques en intérieur je le
précise que les bassins extérieurs
étaient déjà ouverts avec conditions
peuvent également rouvrir ce 19 mai à
accueillir du public
mais là encore pour uniquement les moins
de 18 ans le centre aquatique du lac de
montigny a fait le choix de ne rouvrir
que le 31 mai pourquoi alors il faut
savoir que le public comme unité tente
mineurs ce sont essentiellement les
primaires et secondaires que nous allons
pouvoir accueillir partir du 19 et on a
voulu faire en concertation avec
l'éducation nationale de façon à ce que
le retour de ses enfants soit le plus
rassurant possible au niveau sanitaire
est en fait pour avoir un discours
auprès des parents aussi qu'il le soit
donc on n'a pas voulu se précipiter
on a travaillé sur le projet pédagogique
parce qu'on s'adresse aussi à des
maternelles c'était une première
on devait déjà le faire l'un dernière
mais devant évidemment au vu des
circonstances n'a pas été possible
donc il a fallu que l'on prépare nos
équipes à cela aussi les petites cinq
ans ça n'est pas la même chose que les
10 12 ans donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
pris notre temps et on ne s'est pas
précipité sur le 10 nov
c'est à dire date aujourd'hui et puis on
a aussi l'école de natation que l'on
encadre que toutes mes équipes encadre
et c'est la même chose
ils vont reprendre en même temps que les
autres le 31 mai philippe femmes comment
s'est déroulée la mise en place des
conditions sanitaires des normes des
mesures à respecter au sein vous du club
de basket alors on s'était préparé je
dirais à une reprise sans contact est
évidemment dans ce cadre le protocole
sanitaire est bien plus strictes
en réalité avec le fait que je dirais
cette reprise de 19 mai pour nos mineurs
puissent se faire avec contact essence
opposition fait que nous allons être
vigilants effectivement par rapport à un
certain nombre de règles
en dehors du terrain mais sur le terrain
nous avons aujourd'hui la possibilité
effectivement de pouvoir nous exprimer
de faire exprimer les jeunes tout en
conservant évidemment je dirais un
certain nombre de règles qui nous
permettront d'éviter tout risque a nié
scouarnec comment ça va se passer vous
le 31 mai alors je sais que j'imagine
que vous êtes encore en termes
d'organisation en train de mettre tout
ça en place
quelles sont déjà les mesures à mettre
en place dans une piscine intérieure
face à la crise sanitaire
alors les mesures on les a déjà
expérimenté lors de la réouverture
puisqu'on avait mis en place un
protocole sanitaire sur ce point rien ne
va changer en fait à l'accès à la
piscine se fait par l'entrée principale
on n'y a positionné des distributeurs de
gel hydroalcoolique chaque enfant voit
justement l'utiliser ils viennent à
partir du cp avec leurs masques
jusqu'aux vestiaires le masque une
érotique et retiré qu'à partir du moment
où ils vont se diriger vers les bassins
et contrairement à vie à nos autres
années au lieu d'avoir traque trois
classes en même temps on n'en a qu'une
seule donc ce qui réduit
considérablement le nombre d'enfants on
accueille sur un créneau de 40 minutes
pour nos activités c'est un peu la même
chose puisque en fait ce ne sont pas des
gros groupes ce sont des enfants enfin
des groupes qui vont faire maximum 15
enfants par pour par créneau en traitant
donc de ce point de vue là on n'a pas de
problème particulier et pour ces mineurs
que vous allez accueillir à partir du 31
mai est ce que par exemple le toboggan
du centre aquatique du lac sera ouvert
alors non parce qu'en fait on encadre
uniquement enfin ce sont 7 ouvert
uniquement sur des activités encadrées
ce n'est pas la possibilité de se
baigner d'une baignade libre il faut
savoir que pour une baignade libre il
faut que les enfants est atteint au
moins 12 ans encore n'a encore on a
encore un petit peu de temps devant nous
pour vraiment profiter finalement des
centres aquatiques et des piscines
jusqu'en juin j'espère vraiment la
laveuse y voilà la dernière date c'est
celle d'une joie donc en fonction des
derniers
comment dire consignes qui vont nous
être transmises
on s'adaptera de nouveaux protocoles
s'il le faut et en sorte que l'ensemble
de nos usagers soient accueillis dans
les meilleures conditions
une dernière question pour vous philippe
femmes
la prochaine étape pour vous également
comme les centres aquatiques c'est le 9
juin avec notamment la reprise pour les
adultes pour les majeurs qu'en
attendez-vous de cette reprise
alors effectivement pour les adultes je
dirais l'attentât était encore pire
puisque c'est depuis mi-octobre cas
malheureusement nous adultes n'ont pas
pu remettre les pieds dans dans un
gymnase et n'ont même pas pu pratiquer à
l'extérieur alors que nos jeunes à
partir de mi avril nous avons commencé à
les impliquer sur des parcours extérieur
ce qui n'a pas été le cas pour les
adultes et malheureusement pour les
adultes
malgré cette ouverture qui nous est
faite le 9 juin ça va être des séances
sans contact ça veut dire en réalité
mitigé en termes d'engagement sportif
mais c'est déjà mieux que rien et c'est
surtout je dirais à partir du 30 juin là
où effectivement nous aurons toute
liberté pour remettre en place le jeu
pour les adultes que nous pourront
effectivement vraiment je dirais aller
vers l'entraînement systématique
malheureusement on sait que les la
saison va se terminer vers le 15 juillet
et la sueur à peu de temps avant de
pouvoir remettre en pratique nos adultes
merci philippe à merci agnès coûts
annexes d'avoir été avec nous pour cette
édition spéciale déconfinement merci
vous refermez justement cette édition
spéciale un dernier mot de culture la
demeure d'alexandre dumas au château
monte cristo à port marly est ouverte au
public ce n'était plus possible depuis
le 30 octobre dernier
sauf le parent qui avaient été rouverts
aux visites partiellement reportage de
bérangère bourgoin et bixente mais rien
a insisté ban principal demeure de
l'écrivain alexandre dumas le domaine de
monte cristo est composé du château d'if
et de son cabinet de travail
dès le 19 mai le château de monte-cristo
va rouvrir ses portes et pouvoir
accueillir de nouveau du public avec une
jauge la jauge dans le parc n'est pas
limité en revanche elle le sera dans le
château donc comme l'an dernier quand on
a rouvert en juin 2020 on a rouvert avec
30 personnes autorisées en simultané
dans le château le parc du château avait
déjà rouvert à quelques privilégiés pour
des visites guidées sur réservation
par groupe de 5 maximum ses très bonnes
occasions parce que j'ai effectivement à
deux personnes à voir le parc pour nous
tout seul c'était vraiment intéressant
on avait le temps de voir de discuter
avec la conférencière et le mieux
comprendre le cycle fermé depuis plus de
six mois la directrice du château a vu
son nombre de visites annuelles
dégringolé en principe sur une année on
a entre 25000 et 30000 visiteurs sur une
année là nous sommes bientôt bientôt fin
mai et on en aura eu zéro pour le moment
pas non peut-être avec les petites
visites quelques genres il sait vraiment
rien par rapport à la fréquentation
habituelle le château qui travaille avec
de nombreux artistes prévoit de les
retrouver rapidement le dimanche 13 juin
organise une après midi musical on va
avoir une harpiste qui va venir faire
différentes compositions et puis on aura
aussi un quartet de jazz manouche qui
sera présent tout va se passer dans le
parc
donc ça ira très bien sur le plan
sanitaire
un retour à la normale est donc prévue
pour le 19 mai puisque le château de
monte-cristo rouvrira selon les horaires
habituels du mardi au dimanche et
alexandrine la mascotte du domaine
attend les visiteurs nombreux
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
déconfinement merci de l'avoir suivi vos
programmes se poursuivre sur tv 78 et
d'ici là très bonne soirée à vous
[Musique]